many of Donald Trump's recent interviews
are so short form where he gets such
little time to really flesh out his
Bonkers answers there's just sort of
less of an opportunity for him to hang
himself with his own rope and don't get
me wrong like he still looks like a fool
if you look at that recent interview he
did with Mark Levin he did admit to
crimes specifically obstruction during
the interview completely unprovoked so
he's not coming off like an angel in
those interviews but I have a new
interview from this week that's a little
bit different where Trump was allowed to
sort of go longer maybe less constrained
because it was on Newsmax than by the
sort of fast-paced nature of the Fox
news interview
um you might know that Sean Spicer one
of Donald Trump's former press
secretaries now has a show on Newsmax
and Trump appeared on that show and he
got an opportunity to answer different
types of questions and not only is he
sort of slurring up a storm and sounding
disoriented as often is the case he's
making no sense in terms of this
substance either and telling countless
lies but lies that are important why but
because they signal Trump's plan for
2022 and maybe even for 2024 in terms of
Republican strategy and in terms of his
involvement so let's look at the first
clip the topic of Trump's social media
company truth social comes up we talked
on the bonus show earlier this week
um Donald Trump hired Republican
congressman from California Devin Nunes
to run it Devin Nunes is going to be
resigning from Congress in order to run
Trump's social media company and
immediately Trump is Bomb throwing when
asked about the fact that there's an
Ethics investigation into Devin Nunes of
course there's ethics investigations
into many members of Congress some
Republicans some Democrats there's
nothing particularly pernicious about
this one but immediately Trump is Bomb
throwing take a look at this apparently
according to other reports says already
looking at that company so can you
comment on on Devin nunes's role and the
SEC
well I don't know anything about the SEC
I do know that Devin is fantastic and I
guess we just put out a release and the
release says that he'll be coming on and
you know this is just a continuation of
witch hunts anything you do they want to
look at it they look at it they don't
look at themselves they don't look at
Hunter they don't look at anybody all
they do is look at Republicans Devin is
a fantastic guy I think that he will do
a an incredible job if our side doesn't
have a voice eventually you're not going
to have you're going to end up with pure
communism it's a disgrace what's going
on but you're going to end up with a
communistic communist nation and so uh
Devin we just put out the release on
Devin we're very proud of that we're
proud of him and uh I think it's got a
chance of being a very important uh day
actually I think it's going to be a very
important day always a victim Devin
Nunes is a victim the right are victims
of the social media left wing
everybody's Communists on and on and on
now hilariously this entire interview as
a as of are many of the ones Trump has
been doing lately are supposedly to
promote Trump's book The thing about
Trump's book is that it's a picture book
which is just amazing and in this next
clip I'm going to play for you they have
to suck up to Trump they always do and
Sean Spicer sucks up to Trump by saying
we understand you wrote all of the
captions for the book because remember
it's a picture book most presidents
writing books Trump instead publishing a
picture book in which he writes the
captions it's beyond parody but the
topic is Trump's opinion of what Mike
Pence did on January 6th take a look
history
you know Mr President in the book
there's a picture of you with vice
president Pence
um and you talk about the caption that
you wrote and I understand you wrote all
the captions on these photos says that
you got along great except on one issue
vice president Pence on Thursday said
that he did the right thing on January
6. in your mind did he do the right
thing and is that is that obviously the
one thing that you didn't agree with him
on
uh totally and he didn't do the right
thing and he's a person who's a good
person he didn't have the he didn't do
whatever uh it is that you might say he
should have done because and I think you
agree with me and a lot of people agree
with me if you see that the election was
fraudulent if you see that there are
more votes than there are voters if you
see many of the things that went along
and and they're they're coming out on a
weekly basis more and more and more and
you'll be seeing more come out it's not
me it's States now look at what's going
on in Pennsylvania they're sending
subpoenas to many people and now the
federal government will try and stop
that because they don't want that to
happen they got away with something that
is in my opinion the crime of the
century and instead of going after
antifa and BLM and all these people that
killed a lot of people and burned down
our cities and what they did the
destruction they're going after people
that were protesting the election the
election was the Insurrection the
November third date was the Insurrection
the January 6th date was not the
Insurrection that was the protest this
is really stunning stuff
Trump is still saying it was Pence's
choice not to do what he could have done
to steal the election from the guy who
really wanted and as we've heard from
numerous legal Scholars Pence could not
have done anything to steal it Pence
realized he couldn't steal the election
and he wasn't going to make any kind of
buffoonish attempt to try and that was
the right perspective Pence sought legal
counsel on that and the legal advice was
very very much sound the other notable
thing about this is that Trump has
stopped even pretending that the
violence on January 6th was bad or that
it was carried out by his supporters he
wants to play it both ways Trump's new
story which he seems to be sticking with
is the Insurrection was the November
election I really won and they did an
Insurrection and they stole it and it
led to Joe Biden being declared the
winner that that was the insurrection
per Trump January 6th on the other hand
that was a protest it was a logical
protest because the election was stolen
it was a peaceful protest by my
supporters Trump supporters but any
violence that there was was black lives
matter and it was antifa of course a
claim for which there is absolutely no
evidence and despite that it is Trump's
supporters that are being treated poorly
that's not only an inaccurate revision
of History
it's a very dangerous one because if it
convinces many people and it's
convincing quite a few
it is part of this possible next coup
attempt that we talked about on
yesterday's program
then and this is the last clip that
we'll look at although if this is
interesting if you can stomach this I
encourage you to find the entire
interview it's available online Trump
then does his routine of stating States
in which he did very well he sort of
stopped sort of saying I won these
states but they're states where we did
well and these are states Trump is
looking at being involved in in 2022 and
so this is actually massively
consequential and we're going to talk
about why in a moment but first let's
look at the clip better than most but we
won uh big numbers in Missouri and you
did mention Ohio where we'll also be
involved but we have time I mean it
won't be there won't be primaries for
quite a while in all of those States and
we have some time interesting things
going on in this place that I love is
Pennsylvania you have a lot of very
interesting candidates in Pennsylvania
too so we're going to be involved in the
process yeah
okay Mr President congratulations on the
book uh our journey together is out
tomorrow it's available at 45books.com
as always your time uh is greatly
appreciated and thank you for honoring
us well thank you both very much and
keep up the good work you're doing great
thank you thank you sir thank you sir so
why is this so important it's important
because this is the clearest signal yet
from Trump that he will be involved in
2022 races and he mentions Missouri he
mentions Pennsylvania maybe he's going
to support Dr Oz in Pennsylvania and he
mentions some other states now this is a
signal from Trump about his intentions
the question that remains is whether the
candidates want Donald Trump involved
but if he can raise money for them I
imagine they are certainly going to let
him do it
and without a doubt Trump's preference
would be be involved
endorse and campaign for people who win
and use those successes if it happens to
justify running in 2024 and being the
Republican nominee by saying look at
what I did for us in the midterms that's
his plan he's making it very clear right
now and it very much might work
one of our sponsors is kamikoto making
elegant high-end beautiful Japanese
steel kitchen knives using traditional
techniques from Honshu Japan I've been a
big fan of Japanese kitchen knives for a
long time they have some great
advantages when you look closely at a
kamikoto knife you see the quality of
the iron work they only use Japanese
steel every knife comes in a perfect
heavy duty Ash wood box makes storage
really easy it looks great in your
kitchen or drawer the balance of the
knives is just amazing I've been using
them for everything every knife comes
with a lifetime guarantee on their
website you can see the complete list of
chefs at Michelin star restaurants who
use kamikodo and through this
partnership they're doing with us
kamikoto is giving you 50 off on top of
their other special offers just go to
kamikodo.com Pacman and use the code
Pacman for fifty dollars off the link is
down below